Hello everyone.
Thank you to the AI engineering
world fair team for providing this
wonderful opportunity to share my
research. It is truly an honor to be
speaking alongside so many talented
researchers and practitioners. My name
is Varsha Shah.
I am an enterprise technical architect
working at Tata Consultancy Services
working for Microsoft.
I'm focused on artificial intelligence
enterprise compliance, finance
governance, and intelligent automation.
Today, I would like to share my research
on AI-driven multi-document correlation
for enterprise financial compliance and
fraud detection.
As organizations continue to digitalize
their operations today, they generate a
numerous amount of data
for the financial system across payroll,
tax, procurement, transaction system.
Ironically, while we have more data than
ever before, compliance teams continue
to struggle with hidden fraud patterns,
regulatory risk.
The reason is the most
existing solution analyze the documents
independently. While many of the most
critical risk only become visible when
the information is connected across the
multiple systems.
In this presentation, I'll introduce you
to a framework that combines the
graph-based entity
correlation,
probabilistic risk modeling, and
cross-jurisdictional normalization to
uncover these hidden relationships and
transform enterprise compliance from
reactive process into proactive
intelligence capability. The framework
was evaluated using approximately 3
million financial records across four
jurisdictional
demonstrating both the strong detection
performance and meaningful operations
improvement. With that context, let's
begin
by looking at the compliance gap that
organizations continue to face today.
Let's begin by understanding the
compliance gap that many organizations
continue to face. Enterprise compliance
has become significantly more complex
over the last decade. Organizations now
operate across multiple countries,
regulatory frameworks, and financial
system, each with own reporting
standards and compliance requirements.
At the same time, the volume of the
enterprise has grown exponentially.
Payroll records, tax filings,
procurement transactions, and financial
documents are generated every day,
making manual reviews both
time-consuming and increasingly
impractical. Adding to this challenge,
fraud has been evolved.
Modern fraud rarely appears as an
obvious error within a single document.
Instead, it exploits subtle
inconsistency across multiple system.
Patterns that often remain invisible
when the records are reviewed
independently.
This creates a fundamental limitation.
Traditional rule-based and
document-level NLP system are designed
to validate individual records,
but they are not built to understand
relationship across the documents. And
that's the gap this research aims to
address. Moving beyond this isolated
document analysis to uncover the hidden
risk through the cross-document
correlation. To better understand this
limitation, let's look at why
traditional document level analysis
often fail to detect the most
sophisticated fraud patterns.
To understand why traditional approaches
struggle, let's consider how most
compliance system operates
nowadays.
They evaluate each document
independently. A payroll register is
validated against the payroll rules. The
vendor invoices are checked against the
procurement policies. A tax filing is
reviewed under the tax regulations. If
each document passes its individual
validation, the transaction is generally
considered compliant.
The challenge is that many sophisticated
fraud patterns doesn't
really appear within a single document.
They emerges only when the multiple
documents are analyzed together. For
example, a payroll record may appear
accurate to us. A
vendor invoice may seem legitimate to
us. A tax filing may be correctly
submitted. But, when these records are
connected, they're revealing the
inconsistencies and indicate the fraud
and compliance risk. The information
already exists. What missing is the
ability to understand the relationship
between these documents. That is why the
research shifts the focus from document
level validation to cross document
intelligence, enabling the organizations
to detect the risk that would otherwise
remain hidden. So, if the problem is
understanding relationships rather than
individual documents, what kind of
architecture can solve this? Let me
introduce you to the framework.
Now that we have established the
problem, let's look at the proposed
framework. Rather than relying on a
single model or algorithm, the solution
is built on three
complementary components that work
together to transform the raw enterprise
data into the actionable compliance
intelligence. The first component is the
entity correlation engine.
It
the purpose of this is to connect the
related information across the payroll,
tax, procurement, financial systems,
creating a unified view of enterprise
activity rather than isolated records.
Once these relationships are
established, the second component that
is adaptive probabilistic risk model
which is which evaluates the connected
data to determine which pattern
represent meaningful compliance.
Instead of generating alerts based on
single rule, it
it prioritizes the cases using the
multiple risk signals here.
The cross-jurisdictional normalization
layer provides the regulatory context by
standardizing the currency, tax
structure, reporting standards,
and compliance rules across the
different jurisdictions. This ensures
that the risk are evaluated consistently
regardless of where the transaction
originated.
So, individually, each component
provides a value. Together, they enable
the framework that move beyond the
document validation and towards the
enterprise-wide compliance intelligence.
In the next few slides, I'll briefly
explain you how each of these components
contribute to the process. So, let's
begin with the foundation of the
framework, the entity correlation
engine, which makes the cross-document
intelligence possible.
So, the first component is graph-based
entity correlation engine.
The role is to connect the entities
across the payroll, tax, procurement,
financial system into unified network.
Rather than analyzing the documents
independently, it
it identifies the relationship between
the employee, vendors, account,
transaction,
regulatory files. And these connections
reveal the hidden pattern and structural
anomalies that are often invisible to
the traditional document level analysis
we were doing.
In simple terms, this component answers
one fundamental question, what is
connected? It provides the relation
relational fundamental for the rest of
the framework. Once those relationships
are established, the next step is
determining which one actually
represents the meaningful risk.
Once relationships have been
established, the next step is to
determine which one actually represents
meaningful risk. That's the role of the
adaptive probabilistic risk model.
Instead of relying on static rules, it
combines the multiple risk indicators
such as anomaly
anomaly strength or the source
reliability historic patterns has
happened to calculate confidence best
risk score. This helps prioritize the
cases that require immediate attention
while reducing the unnecessary
investigations. The important advantage
is its ability to learn from the audit
outcomes, allowing the models to
continuously improve its accuracy over
the time. Simply put,
this component answers the question that
what is most likely to be genuine
compliance risk.
Once we have identified the high-risk
cases, the final step is to ensure those
risk are interpreted consistently across
the different regulatory environments.
The final component is
cross-jurisdictional normalization
layer. Global organizations operate
across different countries, currencies,
tax structure, and reporting standards.
Without normalization, the same
transaction can be interpreted
differently depending on the
jurisdiction.
This layer
harmonizes the financial data by
standardizing the currencies, tax rules,
the reporting periods, and the
classification schemes as well. As a
result, the risk are evaluated
consistently regardless of where the
where it has originated. In short, this
component answers to the question, "How
should the risk be interpreted within
the appropriate regulatory context?"
With all these components working
together, the next step was the
evaluated how the framework performs
under real-world enterprise conditions.
So, before discussing the result, let's
um
uh it's it's very important to uh
briefly understand the evaluation of the
environment. The framework was evaluated
using the approximately 3 million of the
financial records collected over 5 years
of period over the four different
regulatory jurisdictions.
The objective was to assess how the
framework perform under the real
realistic uh enterprise condition and
where uh large volume of interconnected
financial data and varying regulatory uh
requirement introduce the significant
complexity here.
Uh with that foundation established,
let's look at how the framework perform.
So,
how effective was the framework in
detecting hidden compliance risk? Let's
look at the results.
So, here now uh look at the detection
performances. The framework achieved
approximately 91% of precision, meaning
the vast majority of the flat cases were
confirmed as a genuine anomalies here.
At
um it also achieved 87%
um recalls, demonstrating its ability to
identify most true fraud cases while
minimal uh minimizing the misdetections
here.
So, together, these results produce a F1
score that is 0.89,
indicating a strong balance between the
precision and recall here. More
importantly, these results are achieved
across four jurisdictions and large
enterprise scale data, demonstrating
that the framework performs consistently
in the complex real-world uh
environments. The next question is um
equally important. How do these
improvements translate into operational
value for the compliance teams?
Detection accuracy is one part of the
story. The real value um comes from
improving the efficiency of the
compliance
operations.
Beyond detection accuracy, the framework
delivers measurable operational
benefits. One of the most significant
outcome was a 76% uh reduction in false
positive, meaning
um investigators spend uh far less than
reviewing the cases that they uh they're
ultimately legitimate.
So, in addition, the framework reduces
the manual audit efforts by
approximately 40% allowing compliance
teams to be focused on the only
high-risk cases instead of uh routing
the document reviews. Ultimately, uh
this translates into faster
investigations, improved uh resource
utilization, and uh greater confidence
in compliance decisions. In other words,
the uh the framework doesn't just detect
fraud more effectively, it helps
compliance teams work more effectively.
So, these operational improvements
become even more meaningful when we
compare uh the uh the framework with the
traditional rule-based approaches.
This comparison highlights the advantage
of moving beyond the traditional
rule-based system. Uh conventional
approaches are effective at validating
the individual records, but they often
struggle to detect the complex fraud
patterns uh that spans multiple uh
documents and systems.
So, by incorporating entity uh
correlation, probabilistic risk
modeling, and regulatory normalization,
the uh proposed framework consistently
um performs the baseline across the key
performance metrics. The key takeaway is
simple. Connecting data across documents
produces better detection, fewer false
positive, and more actionable, uh,
compliance intelligence than analyzing
the documents is, um, in in isolations.
One of the reason the framework
continues to improve over the time is
that, uh, doesn't rely on the static
rules anymore. Instead, it continuously
learn from the completed audit and
investigate,
uh, and the investigator feedbacks here.
So, this framework is designed to
continuously improve through the
feedback. Every, uh, completed audit
provides the valuable information. Uh,
confirm the fraud case, strengthen the
future detection pattern. While false
positive helps refining the risk scoring
and reduce the unnecessary alerts. This
create a continuous learning cycle where
the system becomes more accurate with
each audit and investigation.
As fraud patterns evolve and business,
uh, environments changes, the framework
adopts rather than relying on manual
rule updates. In simple terms, every
completed audit helps make the next
audit more efficient. This continue, uh,
continue learning, uh, capability
enables a broader shift here. From
reactive to compliance issue after they
occur to identifying the risk before
they become audit, uh, findings here.
It's more of a proactive.
Beyond improving detection accuracy,
this framework changes how organization
approach compliances.
Traditionally, the compliance has been
reactive. Issue were identified after
audits, investigation, or regulatory
reviews have happened. This framework
enables more proactive approach through
continuous, uh, monitoring, cross
document correlation, adaptive learning.
Instead of asking what went wrong,
organizations can begin asking what is
likely to go wrong next. That shifts
from reactive validation to predictive
governance, allowing the compliance
teams to identify the risk earlier,
prioritize the investigation more
effectively, and make better informed
decisions. Ultimately, the compliance
becomes an ongoing intelligence
functions rather than a periodic review
process.
While the framework is uh research
driven, it has been designed with the
enterprise deployment in mind.
Successful implementation depends on uh
four key consideration. First one is
seamless integration with existing
enterprise systems such as ERP, payroll,
procurement, tax
uh tax platforms. Second, the
jurisdictional specific uh configuration
to ensure the compliance with local
regulations and reporting standards.
Third one is um
alignment with the audit framework
enabling the investigator to focus on
prioritized risk code cases instead of
manual document reviews. And finally,
scalability. The evaluation demonstrate
that the framework can effectively
process millions of financial records um
making it suitable for the large
enterprise environments.
Uh so, together these uh consi- these
considerations help bridge the gap
between the research and the practical
enterprise adoption.
As I conclude, I would like to leave you
with four key takeaways. First is many
of today's most significant compliance
and fraud risk exist between the
documents, not within them.
Detecting these risk require more beyond
document level analysis and cross
document intelligence.
Second is combining the graph based
entity correlation, probabilistic risk
modeling, and cross jurisdictional
normalization creates a more
comprehensive and scalable approach to
enterprise compliance.
Third is the result demonstrated that
this
particular framework is not only
improves the detection accuracy, but
also
reduces the false positive and
significantly lowers the manual audit
efforts, delivering the measurable
operational value. Finally, by
continuous learning from the audit
outcomes, and the framework enables
the organizations to move beyond
reactive compliance toward predictive
intelligence driven
risk management here. I believe this
represents an
important step toward the future of
enterprise financial govern- governance,
where AI is not only helping the
organizations to detect risk, but also
anticipates and
prevent this risk going forward.
So, thank you once again to the AI
Engineering World Fest team for this
wonderful opportunity, and thank you all
for your time and attention. Please feel
free to reach out to me
with your questions and your enthusiasm
on this email below, or connect me on
the LinkedIn. I'm happy to help you. If
you're building with such kind of
amazing systems for compliances using
the AI wanted to transform them, and
thank you all again. See you next time.